I found out about Ryan Dunn passing from
a call from TMZ asking me for a comment
about it
that's six o'clock in the morning some
of the comments when like people bring
up TMZ they're like oh God they get
their news from TMZ but like TMZ is
really incredible right yeah I think TMZ
is a legitimate news source they hear it
first a lot of times yeah when Cody died
yeah if anything that's the argument
against TMZ is like you guys are too
fast it's kind of creepy it's kind of
weird like you should let the families
find out about this at their own pace or
whatever they found out about Kanye West
divorce before he found out about it
yeah